le cdas 9 7 4 tv le département de la
réunion représente le 22e championnat
régional d'ortona le titre en route pour
cilaos en route pour cilaos à la ligne
calve a dit à son ami chris calva dit à
son ami chris deux points ouvrez les
guillemets pour détendre l'atmosphère
pour détendre l'atmosphère virgules
demain
demain virgules je t'emmènerai à cilaos
je t'emmènerai à cilaos virgule l'homme
de nous dire que montanes yeux l'un de
nos cirques montagneux points
le déplacement en vaut la peine
le déplacement
le déplacement en vous en vous la belle
le déplacement en vaut la peine
point tu oublieras des ennuis tu
oublieras des ennuis pendant une journée
au moins pendant une journée au moins
poil
à la ligne tyrrell alors alors virgule
va pour cilaos va pour cilaos point
d'exclamation
fermez les guillemets fin de la dictée
pour les cm à la ligne 6h30
6h30
point de suspension la petite voiture
jaune
la petite voiture jaune virgules
piloté d'une main sûre par khalfa piloté
d'une main sûre par khalfa pire qu'une
aval gaillardement la petite voiture
jaune virgule piloté d'une mesure par
kahn va bien nulle aval gaillardement
les virages en épingle à cheveux les
virages en épingle à cheveux points
et ils abondent sur cette route et ils
abondent sur cette rude
point à la ligne
agrippée de la main gauche a son siège à
gripper de la main gauche
agrippée de la main gauche à son siège
par son siège virgule de la droite à la
portière de la droite à la portière
virgules
à chaque tournant à chaque tournant
crise appuyé crise a cuit
instinctivement instinctivement sur une
imaginaire de frein sur une
imaginaire de frein points jamais
jamais route ne lui apparut route ne lui
a paru plus dangereuse plus dangereuse
points fin de la dictée pour les cm2 à
la ligne sur les 37 km de son parcours
sur les 37 km de son parcours
sur les 37 km de son parcours virgules
elle côtoie constamment elle côtoie
constamment d'impressionnants précipice
d'impressionnants précipice virgule des
gorges abruptes des gorges abruptes au
fond desquelles
des gorges abruptes au fond desquelles
coule un mince filet d'eau coule un
mince filet d'eau points une chute là
dedans une chute là dedans et et points
de suspension à la ligne
le panorama est grandiose
le panorama est grandiose points de
chaque côté de la rivière
de chaque côté de la rivière bienvenus
les flancs apic des montagnes les flancs
apic des montagnes semble vouloir
écraser semble vouloir écraser le
minuscule voyageurs minuscule voyageurs
sous leur masse impressionnante sous
leur masse impressionnante points fin de
la dictée pour les sixièmes à la ligne
plus on s'enfonce vers l'intérieur de
l'île
la lune
en s'élevant jusque au dessus de 1000
mètres en c le vent jusqu'au dessus de
1000 mètres virgule plus le goulet
montagneux s'élargit plus le goulet
montagneux s'élargit pour finalement
déboucher sur le vaste cirque pour
finalement déboucher sur le vaste cirque
virgules
au terrain accidenté au terrain
accidenté virgule chaotique chaotique
point à la ligne
les énormes blocs de roche de plusieurs
milliers de tonnes les énormes blocs de
roche de plusieurs milliers de tonnes
les énormes blocs de roche de plusieurs
milliers de tonnes évoque évoque un
champ de bataille de géants un champ de
bataille de géants points
fin de la dictée pour les cinquièmes à
la ligne le cirque de cilaos n'est que
le cirque de cilaos n'est que succession
de crête succession de crête et de
ravines et de ravine au milieu desquels
au milieu desquels la route a du mal à
se frayer un passage
la route a du mal à se frayer un passage
points gare aux conducteurs imprudents
gare aux conducteurs imprudents point
d'exclamation partie
très tôt de saint denis partie très tôt
de saint-denis virgules
les deux amis ont joui les deux amis ont
joui toute la journée de temps splendide
tout l'achever de temps splendide poil
chris chris virgule pas du tout à son
aise durant le trajet pas du tout à son
aise durant le trajet bien qu'une crise
via qu'une pas du tout à son aise durant
le trajet virgule a oublié son
appréhension à oublier son appréhension
au coeur du village de cilaos au coeur
du village de cilaos dont le charme un
peu désuet et enchanteur dont le charme
un peu désuet et enchanteur points
fin de la dignité pour les quatrièmes à
la ligne en toile de fond virgules
en toile de fond virgule la masse du
piton des neiges la masse du piton des
neiges virgule avec c'est 3000 m avec
ses 3000 m virgule veille sur le cirque
veille sur le circuit tel un gardien
vigilant
tel un gardien vigilant points les deux
hommes regrettèrent les deux hommes
regrettait de ne pas disposer de ne pas
disposer de plus de temps de plus de
temps pour en entamer la kz cure sion
pour en entamer la kz cure sion point à
la ligne
une auberge coquette les accueillit
agréablement à midi
agréablement à midi de voir ils firent
honneur à
ils firent honneur à un succulent repas
un succulent repas points puis ils
reprirent la route
courageusement puis ils reprirent la
route
courageusement
point final vous pouvez mettre le nom de
l'auteur jules bénard
je relis le texte de la dictée fait très
attention c'est le moment ou jamais si
vous n'avez par hasard oublier un petit
mot en de l'écrire alors en route pour
cilaos calva dit à son ami crise pour
détendre l'atmosphère
demain je t'emmènerai à cilaos l'un de
nos cirques eux montent annuler le
déplacement en vaut la peine
tu oublieras tes ennuis pendant une
journée au moins alors vapo cilaos
6h30 la petite voiture jaune piloté
d'une main sûre par calvin aval
gaillardement les virages en épingle à
cheveux et ils abondent sur sept au
monde
agrippée de la main gauche à son ciel de
la droite à la portière
à chaque tournant crise appuyé est
activement sur une imaginaire de
frein jamais route ne lui a paru plus
dangereuse
sur les 37 km de son parcours elle
côtoie constamment d'impressionnants
précipice des gorges abruptes au fond
desquelles coule un mince filet dont une
chute de là dedans et le panorama est
grandiose de chaque côté de la rivière
les flancs apic des montagnes semble
vouloir écraser le minuscule voyageurs
sous leur masse impressionnante plus on
s'enfonce vers l'intérieur de l'île
en s'élevant jusque au dessus de 1000
mètres plus le goulet montagneux
s'élargit pour finalement déboucher sur
le vaste cirque au terrain accidenté
chaotique les énormes blocs de roche de
plusieurs milliers de tonnes évoque un
champ de bataille une géant le cirque de
cilaos n'est que succession de crête et
de ravine au milieu desquels la roue
a du mal à se frayer un passage
gare aux conducteurs imprudents
partie très tôt de saint denis
les deux amis ont joui toute la journée
d'un temps splendide crise
pas du tout à son aise durant le trajet
a oublié son appréhension au coeur du
village de cilaos dont le charme un peu
désuet est enchanteur en toile de fond
la masse du piton des neiges avec ses
3000 mètres veille sur le cirque tel un
gardien vigilant
les deux hommes regrettèrent de ne pas
disposer de plus de temps pour en
entamer la kz curation une auberge
coquette les accueillit agréablement à
midi ils firent honneur
un succulent repas puis ils reprirent la
route courageuse
pouvait trouver la dictée cette année
face il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
de grosses difficultés
on ne peut vraiment pas de grosses
difficultés mais on a dû utiliser les
questions subsistent subsidiaire pour
départager mais vous avez dit et enfin
les champions on a vu faire appel ou que
celui d'hier donc il ya eu il ya eu de
très bonnes de très bonne 10 p en chemin
c'est une surprise en fait ce que je
pensais avoir fait plusieurs fautes et
là bas je retrouve championnat l'heure
je ne m'y attendais pas du tout déjà
savoir qu'il ya vingt mille participants
du but et qu'on ait ben est l'un des
meilleurs en fait c'est je vais me
fallait pour l'orthographe on sait que
c'est très important et très importante
de savoir écrire correctement le
français au sin pendant toute la
scolarité
on ne donne pas les règles vairelles
autographes aux enfants les adultes ne
seront pas écrire correctement le
français et il faut un travail régulier
régulier pour faire des progrès et que
tous les enfants puissent faire de nude
progrès en autographes les années
précédentes pour l'inde est arrivé qu'on
est des zéro faute mais
c'est assez exceptionnel parce que à ce
niveau de la compétition
parce que c'est une compétition après
tout bien les obstacles sont plus
nombreux parfois ils sont très subtiles
on a le cas pour le mot sur par exemple
la la petite voiture jaune piloté d'une
main sur paris calva il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui ont écrit sfr ça n'a pas
du tout le même sens on entend sur mais
ça s'écrit pas comme on l'entend une
faute qui est revenu assez souvent cee
atmosphère atmosphère ath c'est curieux
mais c'est comme ça c'est bizarre
et puis qu'est-ce que vous avez encore
comme fonte qui revient qui est revenu
là
six heures 6 heures il faut écrire en
lettres et non pas aux chiffres depuis
de nombreuses années depuis que le
championnat d'orthographe existe le
champion le champion bénéficie d'une
d'un voyage à paris d'une semaine
culturelle à paris et au cours de cette
semaine culturelle visite ce qui est le
plus important a visité à paris et ils
vous ont reçu reçu à l'assemblée
nationale généralement et aux seniors 20
je suis très heureuse de pouvoir partir
à paris et pendant une semaine et de
gagner tous les autres prix qui sont
avec aussi ça entraîne pour les concours
pour plus tard et aussi parce qu'on
gagne des choses sympas et c'est en
train de l'esprit de compétition